У нас є деяке відео, відзняте іранським громадянином,
коли літак уже злетів. Він був у вогні. Схоже, що
стався невеликий вибух, наче спалах перед тим,
як літак впав на землю. Після цього падіння
стався вже набагато більший вибух, який, схоже,
і вбив усіх, хто був на борту.
Ресурс трекінгу польотів flightradar24 не показує
жодних проблем із траєкторією польоту
та набором висоти і потім раптом інформація про політ обривається.
Це, можливо, сталося через вибух і, можливо,
у кабіні пілота, що і вразило електроніку.
На flightradar24 дані неповні, і треба ще дочекатися
інформації від них. Але, звісно, схоже, що таки
стався якийсь вибух на борту, зважаючи на те, що
можна побачити з відео, яке зробив іранський громадянин.
Ви кажете про вибух. Чи вважаєте Ви, що цей вибух
був саме всередині літака? Бо цей інцидент стався
саме тоді, коли Іран запускав балістичні ракети по цілях в Іраку.
У будь-якому разі, на мій погляд, цей вибух відбувся
всередині літака. Це був такий собі невеликий спалах.
Під час старту літак світився. Це і привернуло увагу
іранського громадянина, який зняв відео.
Зазвичай ви бачите сигнальні вогні для навігації,
однак небо освітило дуже яскраве світло,
тож мав місце вибух перед падінням на землю.
Тому я вважаю, що літак загорівся від чогось.
Я не думаю, що це сталося внаслідок ракетного удару,
тому що ракета знищила б літак повністю.
Розкажіть, будь ласка, про загальні показники безпеки
польоту цього літака i авіакомпанію, яка його обслуговувала.
Модель (Boeing. - Ред.) 737-800 - це частина так званої
серії нового покоління - моделі 737-700/800 і 900.
Загалом 7000 таких літаків побудували
й експлуатують по цілому світу.
Ця модель має чудові показники безпеки польотів.
Насправді це найбільш надійний літак, який
використовується в комерційних рейсах на сьогоднішній день.
Міжнародні авіалінії України працюють з 1992 року.
В авіапарку - 38 літаків, які здійснюють рейси за 88 напрямками
у Європі, США, Канаді та на Близькому Сході.
Ця авіакомпанія також має чудові показники безпеки
і дотримується усіх головних міжнародних правил безпеки,
тож усе покажуть чорні скриньки.